Elon Musk has bought Twitter for approximately 44 billion.
He's going to be paying each share of Twitter $54.20.
In a statement released by the company,...
Mr. Musk said, "Free speech is the bedrock of a functioning democracy...
...and Twitter is the digital town square...
...where matters vital to the future of humanity are debated.
I also want to make Twitter better than ever...
...by enhancing the product with new features,...
...making the algorithms open source to increase trust,...
...defeating these spam bots and authenticating all humans.
Twitter has tremendous potential.
I look forward to working with the company...
...and the community of users to unlock it."